[Music]
communicating underwater is challenging
light and odors don't travel well so
it's hard for animals to see or smell
but sound moves about four times faster
in water than in air so in this dark
environment marine mammals often rely on
vocalization to communicate that's why a
chorus of sounds fills the ocean
clicks pulses whistles groans boeing's
cries and trills to name a few
but the most famous parts of his
underwater symphony are the evocative
melodies for songs composed by the
world's largest mammals whales whale
songs are one of the most sophisticated
communication systems in the animal
kingdom only a few species are known to
sing blue fin bowhead minke whales and
of course humpback whales these are all
baleen whales which use hairy baleen
plates instead of teeth to trap their
prey meanwhile toothed - whales do use
echolocation and they and other species
of baleen whales make social sounds such
as cries and whistles to communicate but
those vocalizations lack the complexity
of songs so how do they do it land
mammals like us generate sound by moving
air over our vocal cords when we exhale
causing them to vibrate baleen whales
have a u-shaped fold of tissue between
their lungs and their large inflatable
organs called laryngeal sacs
we don't know this for sure because it's
essentially impossible to observe the
internal organs of a living singing
whale but we think that when a whale
sings muscular contractions in the
throat and chest move air from the lungs
across the youthful and into the
laryngeal sacs causing the you fold to
vibrate the resulting sound resonates in
the sacs like a choirs singing in a
Cathedral making songs loud enough to
propagate up to thousands of kilometers
away whales don't have to exhale to sing
instead the air is recycled back into
the lungs creating sound once more one
reason whale songs are so fascinating is
their pattern units like moans cries and
chirps are arranged in phrases repeated
phrases are assembled into themes
multiple themes repeated in a
predictable pattern create a song this
hierarchical structure is a kind of
grammar whale songs are extremely
variable in duration and whales can
repeat them over and over in one
recorded session a humpback whale sang
for 22 hours and why do they do it we
don't yet know the exact purpose but we
can speculate given that the singers are
males and they mostly sing during the
mating season songs might be used to
attract females or perhaps they're
territorial used to deter other males
whales return to the same feeding and
breeding grounds annually and each
discrete population has a different song
songs evolved over time as units or
phrases are added changed or dropped and
when males from different populations
are feeding within earshot phrases are
often exchanged maybe because new songs
make them more attractive to breeding
females this is one of the fastest
examples of cultural transmission we're
learned behaviors are passed between
unrelated individuals of the same
species
we can eat strap on these songs using
underwater microphones called
hydrophones these help us track species
when sightings or genetic samples are
rare for example scientists have been
able to differentiate the elusive blue
whales populations worldwide based on
their songs but the oceans are getting
noisier as a result of human activity
boating military sonar underwater
construction and seismic surveys for oil
are occurring more often which may
interfere with whales communication some
whales will avoid key feeding or
breeding grounds if human noise is too
loud and humpback whales have been
observed to reduce their singing in
response to noise 200 kilometers away
limiting human activity along migratory
routes and in other critical habitats
and reducing noise pollution throughout
the ocean would help ensure whales
continued survival if the whales can
keep singing and we can keep listening
maybe one day we'll truly understand
what they're saying
[Music]